Bushwick I want to know a little bit
about this home first well I understand
you were injured on the set of this film
I was I I ran into a car to try to break
shattered glass and I injured my rib now
why it sounds like that's a way that you
would obviously get injured if he told
you hey Brittany run into that car as
hard as you can and try and shatter
glass that sounds like a hundred percent
chance you're gonna get injured I'm a
really committed actress I don't know I
I yeah I'm an idiot also um I thought I
could just break this shatter glass by
by running really hard into it and the
glass did not shatter right but my rib
did oh you broke your rib I didn't break
it but yeah it was very badly injured so
um yeah I'm really hard core yeah you
have bad representation a new manager
immediately that was I wouldn't I
wouldn't let you do that if I everything
if I was running your career I wouldn't
let that happen
yeah okay I'll confide in you from now
on so yeah you sort of just did right
here
you